so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast I'm here with my
co-host Marty O'Neal surprise that's
calm what's up guys how you doing
today's episode I'm very excited I'm uh
gonna dive straight into this guys this
is the milk episode how you doing man
what's the deal bro I'm good bro how you
doing man for sure thank you for being
here are you off top first off we've
been talking for about half an hour guys
we've just been getting set up because
you were actually early and better than
being on time like I said we've had many
guests just
bro I'm two hours late but come on I
feel bad but like you said like no I
don't be late to stuff I'll be early
appreciate that but with that being said
we've been talking and talking and
talking so I want to get right into what
I was talking for I forget about it
YouTube you're about to hit 100 100 000
subscribers yeah you're like I saw this
when you're right you're right there
like a couple nights away it looks like
right yeah yeah I'm right around yeah
it's dope dude so for everyone out there
just explain what you do as a YouTuber
what is your style of
of videos or what would you say like no
this is what I do bulk of and sometimes
I'll do that because there's people out
there that YouTube is a real it's a real
career man yeah you're paying your bills
off it yeah yes you don't have to go to
work no more yeah exactly it is work
it's like I'm gonna roll a blunt what am
I gonna talk about today yeah I mean I
don't have to go clock I don't have to
go to nobody else job I'm working for me
but uh YouTube I do reactions uh what
type of reactions
I kind of started off
um
I wasn't even doing reactions at first I
was just doing little topics talking
about game stuff or just talking about
how I grew up in different [ __ ] like
that and then people started like making
videos on me saying stuff like oh who is
this guy he's not from L.A he's fake or
some [ __ ] like this so that's how the
reaction video started because I started
basically reacting to their videos but I
would just do my intro put the little
clip of the video that they talking
about and then talk after until I
learned how to like uh actually
spontaneously yeah do the reaction so I
just started off like that and then it
just it just went from there with the
reactions and for everyone out there
that's like nah it takes so much to be a
YouTuber like you just said you were
doing an off Obama phone yeah it wasn't
even it wasn't even Obama phone it's
like a Life Alert like if you get your
grandma or your oh or your old mother
and if she fall she could have this
phone to call the people to come how'd
you get it it was in my drawer it was in
I don't know I think it was maybe my
girl Mother's or something I don't know
but I just got it one day and I was like
okay I'm gonna record off of it and um I
was working too at the same time like a
real job where at uh this the last job
was Hotel Figueroa I had opened that on
uh Olympic and fig no [ __ ] yeah that was
one of the first employees the first
group no way all right so you're
actually working out there getting it
not just this YouTube's not working I
just need like donations from you guys I
can't stand that [ __ ] you're still doing
YouTube while working because it doesn't
work no I start no no I was working
first like I wasn't even I don't know
what YouTube that's what I meant like
you're still working because it's like
because most people like no I need
donations
no no graveyard shift 50 maybe 50 60
hours a week oh you're working working
yeah all right what did you do there uh
restaurant I was a porter supervisor so
I started off as a dishwasher in there
that was the easiest part to get in but
that was paying good then like five
months later I became like the porter
supervisor so I was just like the the
lead dishwasher I put the produce away
receive all the products make sure
they're doing what I used to do make
sure they're doing their job and [ __ ]
like that so I was getting cool money
but I was working and then every day I
go home I start doing the YouTube
see if you really like something you'll
like I said I I was working at U-Haul
how many places just because I couldn't
sell weed no more because I started
doing content like I'm gonna get my door
kicked in doing this content with all
those packs yeah like I was trying to
explain to you so it's good to hear that
Max not but wait how old are you I'm 29.
oh okay so you see you're not a little
kid man so you have that work ethic in
you and I'm not saying all little kids
are lazy I'm saying you probably have
some younger cousins like yo get up yeah
do it do something do something that's
how I feel too so you started doing
YouTube off this Life Alert phone which
is the craziest [ __ ] I ever heard and
you started doing reaction videos and it
got popular enough to where people
started reacting to you yeah yeah um
like when I I got into YouTube because
like when I when I be at work or when I
get home I'll be smoking and I and I
found out what YouTube was I didn't even
know what it was before
2000 and 17. that's crazy but I really
was never like on YouTube or nothing I
was outside and you know just doing [ __ ]
like that so I started I found out what
YouTube was and I started watching
videos and you know spare time watching
different stuff then I started seeing
these videos talking about La just
talking about different [ __ ] they didn't
know what they were talking about so
that kind of gave me the idea like do
YouTube then I'm like nah cause then I
can't be I don't want to get in front of
no camera and be talking because that's
just how I grew up like yeah I kind of
was in the streets there's no pictures
ever yeah but then I was like
um
people rap it's rappers and [ __ ] like
this and I'm like so when I did it it
wasn't really too many people like doing
what I was doing in La already I mean it
was like DJ ghost but I really didn't
know who he was but he already been out
probably
four years before I even started so it
wasn't really nobody in the lane that I
was in yeah and they just started
popping kind of
okay so you say you're from here where
are you from exactly in La uh Los
Angeles South Central okay okay um so
there's a thing I like to do real quick
uh I thought of this question once I
went I'm gonna ask all the guests this
question so you're 29 right now your 16
year old self
are you gonna beat the [ __ ] out of him
or he's gonna [ __ ] you up because 16
year old self of me would beat the [ __ ]
out of him Buff Ass full that's like a
question I was like would you young
yourself beat your ass that's just a
question like all right let me get back
to the gym I got when I ask that people
go [ __ ] he probably wouldn't mind he
probably beat my ass back he probably
would do something else oh okay
could you imagine like my younger self
shot me
it's a good indicator to know like how
you're doing it yeah no it is
just 12. I don't know you know but no
it's just a it's just a gauge man I love
that question it's a gauge of like
all right so so you grew up in obviously
South Central I watched something this
is how this all went down you talked to
Marty Marty talked to me and I'm like
wait I've seen this fool before where
yeah and then you showed me go oh
another interview that's where I seen
him yeah and then I looked a couple of
your videos
and obviously you didn't grow up in the
suburbs no so I'm from Merced I don't
know if you know where Merced is the
[ __ ] ghetto of the Central Valley
it's Gangland Merced Merced by Fresno
okay yeah yeah
[ __ ] like that uh it's up more up north
it's between Victorville [ __ ] like that
like stop oh so you've been up there but
I know what it is yeah that's past me
I'm in the I'm we're the Dead Center
California it's nothing but meth and
gangs bro so you grew up in Gangland too
I grew up in gang I'm wearing group in
the shitty part of Buffalo
so I remember but since you grew up in a
tough environment I know you remember
what was the first time you ever got in
a fight how did it go down well how old
were you
the first real fight real I got into
real fight I I was probably like 12
years old and um oh what time is it we
could smoke a joint now yeah we always
wait a little bit so we're in trouble I
was 12 years old and um
I had just met these people I moved to
53rd and dinker and uh
I was on a bite and I was on the pegs
like riding with somebody on a bike and
I had another peg in my hand and I was
trying to throw it to the yard where my
homie lived at but it was somebody
standing right there and the peg ended
up hitting him in his head somebody that
lived across the street like kind of
like my friend and you yeah so then we
ended up having a fight right there was
it your age yeah he's my age oh okay I'd
fight you too are you hitting with the
pegs
of course I kind of he probably think I
did it on purpose but I really didn't
yeah of course and I had other fights
like right after that I had a fight with
my friend over a bike over like a uh BMX
and fights over here we used to we used
to like uh uh strip bikes and [ __ ] like
just trying to take the tires off learn
how to put the brakes back on do
different [ __ ] so I think I messed up on
his bike now he was bigger than me with
size so that one was kind of crazy I
think I ended up biting him what the
hell were you I was 12. so that's your
homie and you guys fought to the fight
to the point you had to bite his ass
yeah
yeah were you in someone's front yard
yeah yeah I knew it man it's like
someone's mom said just did a drive by
tagging him drive by pegging yeah that
sounds like a different category yeah
but now your story is always interesting
to me when I started watching your
channel because I grew up like my
brother was adopted we grew up like
white man can't jump style and [ __ ] like
me and him the whole time like brothers
people looking at us crazy when we call
each other brothers and [ __ ] like
and you're the only story I've ever
heard that grew up like that like
adopted deep in the hood and [ __ ] and
come out tell your story and be you like
very very super unique like
yeah um I got adopted at seven days old
oh okay the black family well to a black
mother
um you got adopted wait was it a friend
of the family she just went to the
orphanage I want this white baby no she
was already like doing foster um she was
like a foster mother like she had four
kids already then she started becoming a
foster mother but when when she got us
she didn't want to do the Foster uh kids
no more she just wanted to adopt me so
she adopted me at seven days old and she
adopted my brother at 14 days old it's
not my brother like biological brother
but she adopted another boy seven days
after me wow so we grew up as as
brothers I was always seven days old
obviously you're a weak apart I'm burnt
what's that age
I think it's an age difference maybe
like a year yeah yeah this is just when
she got us it happened yeah okay so
that's your little brother yeah I think
like maybe a year younger than me so how
many siblings did you have then well she
already had four kids they was already
older I think her oldest son was maybe
30 something maybe 20 something at the
time because because my sister's name is
already grown it was already in their
20s oh so she's just like 11 her
biological character yeah you see these
houses kind of often like they yeah like
that's hell [ __ ] so she was a foster
brother at first but she said when she
got like before she got us she just
didn't want to do the Foster occasion no
more she just wanted to adopt kids yeah
because I guess he was getting to um
attached to the kids and they gotta go
back that's like a crazy thing my little
brother was all in that system like yeah
I wasn't never in foster care I gotta
adopt it so I got their last name and
everything oh wow so this hospital this
is straight up your whole family your
whole life yeah my mother she had kids
too by my biological brother I defining
who she was later on down maybe when I
was like 23. holy [ __ ] yo from a
Facebook message
not me it was somebody uh I think it was
my brother the other adopted brother
I think she hit him up and you know how
they'd be messages in the uh request and
I think he's seen it for a minute but he
just never told me then one day he told
me how did he know it's her he's
probably knew it was her holy [ __ ] bro
do you ever meet her yeah yeah I met him
chill up cool yeah I saw my mother was a
heroine addict she was on Herobrine I
think so she got I got took for Bert
when she had me but she already had kids
too she had she had other brothers and
sisters no my yeah my uh biological
mother she had kids too before me I was
like the baby so she had a son that was
already he dead he got killed when I was
probably babe I didn't even know him but
he got killed like after he did juvenile
life or some [ __ ] and um she had two
twin daughters so she had three kids
four with me but I got took at the
hospital
damn that's a [ __ ] horrible thing to
have other kids and have one of your
kids just be taken forever what about
the sisters no they was with her see I
don't know if she was that bad like I
don't know if she was that bad on heroin
when she had them or maybe she was just
dibbling that's the positive when you
came yeah or she was just too bad too
far gone or some [ __ ] like that I really
don't know like I really don't [ __ ] with
her like that oh but you did meet her
though yeah I met her okay I took her to
my birthday or I told them to come to my
birthday dinner or some [ __ ] like that I
tell where did where did she uh live in
LA this whole time
um
yeah I think they was in Riverside when
I when when I met them yeah
what about your sister is they still
there too yeah yeah my sister's in this
crazy because I think I didn't see my
sister before and didn't even know that
was my sister holy [ __ ] yeah like a
party or some [ __ ] yeah I think she
lives around the area where I was at
yeah wow that's a that's a trip bro
that's a [ __ ] movie scene right there
but she grew up with your mom does she
know about you they know yeah no they
didn't know who I was because I'm pretty
sure I I think I remember seeing him
before maybe when I was like young and
always had the people like my my sisters
in from the adopted family they used to
always be like you like your mom and
them Daddy but I never knew who the [ __ ]
this lady was but I think I met him
probably when I was like five
or four maybe I remember something like
that but they didn't tell you like this
is your biological family no they said
it oh my mama she was trying to make me
go like with him like to be with him for
some hours or something I didn't want to
do it oh okay I met my grandmother with
the biological grandmother and she was
ordered in long sleeve shirts at the
time so I'm pretty sure she did
yeah
just slid that into her reality
I never heard that expression in my life
I used to rock the [ __ ] on the longest
thing
it was all like some real [ __ ] like
little long sleeve shirts like dude
he had no expression when you said it so
I was like wait yeah oh I like that
that's something that's a good sense
where'd you learn that from what old man
gave you that one I heard it somewhere I
don't know there's some old man that's
why I grew up around old people but I
mean yeah like so I was never around him
I just grew up with as the only white
kid in a black family
from birth pretty much
that must not been easy at school man
what well I mean like like at first when
I was a kid I really didn't even know
the difference oh no I'm saying because
people are ignorant as [ __ ] age yeah
but when I got to middle school I mean
elementary and [ __ ]
oh
I was in in in in a the school was
probably like a white area it was uh
Loyola Elementary it was by the airport
LAX I don't think it's there no more I
think they tore it down to expand the um
airport but I was there for like two
years I was a bad kid at the same time
too but yeah when I when I started going
to the uh the schools in the black areas
it was different but it was regular
though it wasn't really like nothing no
I'm saying because me I grew up in the
Mexican area as a Mexican kid don't
speak Spanish
my grandma's Jewish lady like I was not
and of course it was a lot to [ __ ]
deal with was like all right bro yeah I
don't speak Spanish all right no make
fun of me okay you know what I'm saying
like growing up was different for me so
I was thinking for you like
no yeah I mean I had I had them uh the
situations were were like the people
probably try to pick up me or the little
white kid but I was always bad bro like
I always leaned towards the streets
since our early age like
um my mother she was basically single so
I really didn't have a father and no
[ __ ] like that so by 12 I was already
wanting to go to the streets 11 and a
half I was already and then
they came from Shreveport Louisiana
that's where her uh
mother's name came from so when they
moved out here they got a house on 79th
and Figueroa that's in the Heart
Association that's like in the whole
show so far yeah um so that's where her
mother moved in 1965 before the game
banking event uh took off so that's
where we used to go every weekend or
every day like Terry Mama house on 79th
and fig run around that's when people
used to go to that Grandma house run
around I don't think people do [ __ ] like
that no mother no you're talking about
the 90s though now this early 2000s yeah
it's like early 2000s oh yeah well 99
too right yeah like like the late 90s
guys it's the holidays Santa's watching
last thing you want to be doing is
showing up to the Christmas party with
the overgrown undercarriage manscape
Platinum package 4.0 has got it all for
you to polish up that candy cane and
toast them walnuts up real nice manscape
has got some of their best selling
products and put them all inside of the
Platinum package Christmas is coming up
buy this for your significant other your
boyfriend your husband or your dad but
you know what I'm saying guys it could
be a perfect gift and a little hint a
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer a weed
whacker ear a nose hair trimmer coming
with that skin safe advanced technology
protecting your balls protecting your
dick both are waterproof both got the
nice light on them you're looking real
impressive and real festive and don't
forget manscape has just recently added
top of the line shower products all the
manscape shower products are sulfate
free vegan and they will leave you not
dried out these are hydrating they're
not going to leave you Ashy Larry chalk
dust board right after good times don't
stop in the shower we got the crop
preserver ball deodorant we got the crop
reviver ball toner once they touch your
sack they're never going impact
manscape.com
20 off plus free shipping again twenty
percent off of anything and everything
you buy plus free shipping when you use
our code so that's manscape.com forward
slash Yola twenty percent off plus free
shipping on anything
vpns are great for protecting your
security and privacy by hiding your IP
address and encrypting your traffic to
keep it secure from cyber attackers are
you ready to take your digital security
to the next level nordvpn offers brand
new features to the desktop app to make
sure you are covered when you are on the
internet say you're a Bills fan and you
live in California and you really want
to watch the Bills game but your cable
service provider does not offer it
because you don't live on the east coast
nordvpn will allow you to watch any
sporting event even if it's not in your
region to break it down for you it'll
give you a virtual location as if your
VPN was over there so you could watch
the game just like normal all you have
to do is enable it on your nordvpn app
it's protecting you from malicious
websites malware trackers intrusive ads
that you don't want even if you're not
connected to a VPN server more VPN is
the price of one cup of coffee per month
and can be used on up to six different
devices and if you're not already
convinced nordvpn is the world's fastest
VPN service no buffering no lagging no
stupid Circle going up when you're
trying to stream so right now if you go
to nordvpn.com they have teamed up with
adobe's usual pocket cast to bring you
guys a really big discount so when you
use our code Yola using our code is
going to get you a huge discount plus
four additional months for free and
remember if you don't like it it's a 30
day money back guarantee they're not
here to scam you they're here to protect
you
so damn growing growing up like that
damn adopted seven days that's a
that's a different I don't know dirty
white kid at the uh baby showers the
parties the uh anything everything were
you wandering at all like after you met
your mom was there other times you saw
her were you like thinking about it was
it on your mind uh don't get me wrong it
was sometimes probably when I was
younger yeah maybe like 10 9 11 but just
wondering yeah wondering but not as
quick as it came in it went out like
I'll lie if I say I probably didn't feel
no type of way yeah sad yeah maybe hurt
or wondering why like why am I adopted
or some [ __ ] like that yeah but at the
same time I didn't grow up with a bad
family I didn't I wasn't really like
mistreated or no [ __ ] like that so yeah
I remember like my brother the same
thing he got I told you he got drunk one
time it all kind of came out like kids
just walking around with this and then
it's just on their conscious and [ __ ]
you know and then like it's just
different yeah but I have to get over
that [ __ ] yeah
no for sure for sure but it's always
like you always feel bad for the little
kid like when I was talking like wow
damn that kid that sucked like well that
was me [ __ ] right so I get it could at
least you didn't end up going to a
thousand foster homes and yeah like it
could have been real it could have been
real worse I could have really had a bad
uh yeah apparent and then you got to
think I started thinking like damn so
what if it's better that I'm here and
not there
for sure because it could be probably
worse that's the thing that kind of
happened in my situation like you might
not want to really find out where like
how it could have gone because there
could be a whole [ __ ] up situation
what they saying like oh when they get
drunk don't be like Daddy or you gonna
be just like your mama or something so
I'm like then you start hearing when you
get older like 12 11. your mama's a
crackhead because my sister's name you
know that's how people that's how they
are you know it sounds [ __ ] up but you
know they used to say all type of crazy
[ __ ] you're adopted sister yeah damn
yeah I can get Richard I try I remember
the older cousin so you got no [ __ ]
daddy yeah [ __ ] like that who's your
daddy Marcus damn don't be bringing back
together
it's exactly what he says though I think
um damn Mario don't throw him back on
some classic movies you should have
expected that chance I didn't but that
was good that was good we was always in
L.A um living in L.A ever since I was um
since I can remember but at first the
first house I remember I could vividly
remember was on the east side of L.A in
Manchester maybe Avalon it was somewhere
over there it's like a house because she
always wanted a house my mama she always
and this back then the rent was like
2000 2200 in the 90s so she always had
like a house and we moved on in
Inglewood for like a year then we went
to like Olympia and that's like Crenshaw
and Vernon
it's like is is Overhill or some uh what
is this [ __ ] called Olympia Drive it's
like uh View Park or some [ __ ] it's like
an area over there with like kind of
like upper class then we moved a view
part then I remember her telling us
probably like a 10 or 11 like 10 and a
half if y'all still want all this [ __ ]
for Christmas and these PlayStation I
think maybe it was three at the time it
was PlayStation some tour something it's
like if y'all want this [ __ ] then we
can't we can't live here no more we
gotta oh [ __ ] was she working or was
like having the kids her main like yeah
no that was probably her main income at
that time she was because she was
already older too at the time oh yeah
you said that I forget you 30 something
yeah she was probably when she adopted
us maybe she had to be already in her
late 40s maybe 50s probably early 50
maybe yeah like oh she was Grandma age
already yeah oh wow she just kind of let
you guys like outside like off the leash
like what she kind of looks in your life
trying to well not in trouble no of
course yeah no no she was I was just a
bad kid we wasn't like of course she
used to take us to her Mama house so of
course I'll give exposed to the street a
little bit more but it's like my house
what I mean I had cousins in prison you
know my sisters and baby daddies and
it's [ __ ] like that but uh I didn't have
a no she was really on it like I had to
go to school all type of [ __ ] like I get
whooped beat uh if I [ __ ] up all type of
[ __ ] like that but yeah like I guess our
income was probably her Main
income at the time and then at that time
all my sisters was living in the house
with us the adopted sister [ __ ] so we
had like a five bedroom and it's all of
us in the house and that stopped in
probably like 99. I remember this my
sister moved out
to the apartment machine to this day
which is crazy wow same spot the same
apartment that's wild right I hope she
got that rent control now yeah for sure
it's probably something like that
if they had 1200 still probably a
thousand uh yeah I got one homie like
that that's got a crazy spot out here
she will not leave won't leave we'll
leave a spy he's had it for 10 years
like two it's twelve hundred dollars for
a three beds you know how long that was
but then we moved to 53rd well before
that like when we left the house it was
5119 Marvel Drive I still remember the
address it was a big house uh
it was crazy over there like it wasn't
crazy like that but it was just it was
wild that's where I started like doing
all type of [ __ ] and then when I got to
53rd but before we moved there we moved
to my uh we stayed with my grandmother
for like a month and a half to this like
house was ready my mama got a duplex on
um 53rd and dinker
that's like down the street from the
Slauson Swap Meet okay probably like
three blocks
um and I moved there at like 11 and a
half and that's when the [ __ ] got real
everything
so do you think because like my dad's
was damn meth head oh cool Sorry smoke
crank a lot and he wasn't around no
[ __ ] father figures or of any kind
except my stepdad which is
all right it's a long story my step dad
my mom my mom's Mexican but my other
side my grandma's Jewish white lady
right my Mom married a frustrated white
supremacists go to the prison every
weekend visit his ass Aryan [ __ ] tatted
everywhere all in all the [ __ ]
so that was the only figure in my life
and he was a good one but we had to
visit his ass in prison it was a long
story he's white I'm Brown he's got
swastikas and bolts it's like he taught
you Spanish taught me Spanish it was the
dumbest [ __ ] so so do you feel the
reason I say that is because
your mom kept you out of the [ __ ] she's
telling you got to do this you gotta do
this so did my mom we went to a
different route how did you turn out to
go you know I'm gonna go [ __ ] around
with these Street [ __ ] because I saw it
as I'm gonna get my ass shot I'm gonna
go to school because that's because my I
was in the same position you know what
I'm saying like
strict I'll get my ass beat yeah
my mom was the same so you had a machete
oh [ __ ] she turned it sideways she was
black and had a machete yeah that's a
Mexican thing I'm surprised to hear them
from Shreveport it was from Louisiana
just because when I hear machete I'm
like big Mexican dude Samoan dudes
machete sure oh [ __ ] okay so your mom's
scary too how did you how did you look
at some some dude you know you're not
supposed to chill with and go nah so
we're chilling because I have those
friends and I go hey you guys gonna
chill I'm gonna go but I'll see you
tomorrow I know it's not optional if you
were gonna be outside because I oh I
mean there's always an option but you
might you're a [ __ ] I'm like hey call
me a [ __ ] you're gonna go to prison
that's always the option I mean you
didn't I didn't have to hang around I
mean it started it started yeah because
when I moved over there I was ready for
Middle School I was already so I went to
John Muir oh okay and I uh I will catch
the dash it's the dash it's like yeah
it's like you know not the Metro but it
only goes like a short distance but and
circle back but that's when I used to
catch it used to be a quarter so I used
to catch the bus to school started
meeting people and um I don't know how
broad just always wanted to go [ __ ]
around in the streets I just loved it
for some reason bro so what were you as
a kid what are you doing like you said
you're stripping bikes and [ __ ] yeah
we've done all type of [ __ ] like like 11
and a half we was busting Windows like
going for no reason just this one I was
like still kind of like a kid like 10
and a half eleven yeah we're still in
pipes we was going through everybody the
alleys because they had alleys that's
teas like this so we were just looking
through people's yards to take the
edgers to make mini bikes
um for the motor yeah back then people
used to pit uh they used to put these
things on a tire cap so their cars like
bullets dices
we used to just go around everywhere
stealing them off people cars
wow that's when I was like a kid that's
little kids should still yeah yeah but
but the people I live moved across the
street from who became like my best
friend so I still [ __ ] with to this day
Daddy this is [ __ ] oh so it don't matter
but he used to have a chop shop so
hanging around with him tank I learned a
lot of we started doing a lot of [ __ ] so
that's when the bikes start coming in oh
you're doing the Mini version of like I
want to still bike and chop it yeah we
learned how to jump Gage run on the
walls hit brick walls anything anything
like that with bro he's breaking into
elementary schools it's really for no
reason and chilling yeah just just yeah
yeah writing on the walls kid [ __ ] still
yeah it's still kind of innocent yeah a
little a little bit and then 12 it
changed that's when everything really
like damn are you half a year later it
changed yeah change I was on 53rd and
Dinger bro I was in the harder um
South Central like
it was just it was there anything you
wanted to do was there so I met people
at going to school the people that
probably lived on like a block down he
lived right here so I started meeting
these people we start hanging around
that's when we started like we started
smoking together and [ __ ] then it went
from that uh selling weed it was getting
quarter pounds of stress for like 125
maybe do some [ __ ] like that all right
get that [ __ ] break it down that was
stress that's when we was [ __ ] with
that but [ __ ] that you have to break
still
then the burglary started happening uh
robberies I remember 12 years old we hit
a house bro that we we were stupid
because we used to sit right in this
house at my homie house and he had a
porch that was like fenced in so you go
through a fence and then it's like
another door but it's like bricked up
but half fence so we could sit in there
and smoke and
and just look so there's these people
across the street and for some reason we
just seen them we knew their routine and
then one day we went in there
um and it was wild because we put on
socks like we really did this [ __ ] we
had to go around we couldn't do it on
the Main Street like this is dinker so
it's like cars coming down it's just too
much [ __ ] and then the police station is
probably like
five miles or something so maybe they'll
come down Dinka or something you just
never know so we had to go bro to the
next street jump a fence go through
somebody yard jump another fence and
then go you know we was like already on
the [ __ ] so we knew how to go through
your emergency bar open the window stick
our hand in there pop yo the emergency
window open and um yeah we had a
burglary and I was like 12 I'm not lying
oh cause I didn't know no better bro I
was that's what we was doing it was
different back then I mean yeah yeah
that's just what it was
but I never I never was getting caught
for [ __ ] like we wasn't really getting
caught for [ __ ] we was doing that you
invincible then to yourself selling a
little weed we was having Cars one of
the homies like all of us have a car it
was um at 12 12 13 14 years old yeah
we was outside bro like yeah then it
just started getting a little Wilder
though like [ __ ] start getting wild
that's when the like the game [ __ ]
really start coming
um into play because I was already
claiming the [ __ ] that I'm from but
because of like my grandma like this
were all my my sister's name and and
Mama name kind of grew up with the first
generation of them people that's over
there like the game so I pretty much
knew all the older people the the ogs
OG's right now like all them so I was
already claiming this [ __ ] but then
that's when you know [ __ ] started
happening over there shootings uh it was
wild bro it was like you couldn't even
walk down the street without worrying
about like somebody pulling up or
somebody trying to play with you and say
what's up and get you to the car and
shoot you it was wild bro get you to the
car and shoot oh that's the most devious
[ __ ] I ever heard yeah it was fun over
there I mean I I learned I learned a lot
of [ __ ]
I
don't
think
I like a lot of a lot of [ __ ] I mean
yeah it was something that [ __ ] was bad
though but that's just how it was but I
lost a lot of friends too early over
there like early 12 I had a homie that
died when he was like 12. he went and
got put on his hood and [ __ ] put on my
hood he was claiming something else
I say within like four months
yeah I got gunned down a little boy yeah
I mean back then bro it was growing yeah
if it was grown people running down on
kids they catch a kid that's doing
something or they know their name or
their face or or he banged on them or he
thought the hood up they were shooting
them got shot like eight or nine times
bro before that I think one of my homies
he for sure got killed but I think it
was over like a burglar that people
found out about
and um they sprayed his [ __ ] up he was
17 in Alexis this one like 48th and
Western or something associated right to
the side like on a movie and just
um so easy to happen bro
and people people don't realize
everything's got a consequence
everything that's why so that's why I
asked that question it was you know if I
do this I hang out with these fools I'm
definitely getting my ass no for sure at
home why not even punching the face I
used to hide the [ __ ] yeah and I used to
try to hide it as much as I could at
first but I mean she kind of probably
knew okay because you hold yourself just
the way you carry yourself I think they
said I had a ADHD some [ __ ] like that
but I'm like I mean I think my mama is a
meth head so that's probably why that's
all my excuses [ __ ] I had my mom on here
the show me my mom are cool now we
weren't that cool before and uh yeah
now I'm like all right Mom remember that
time you did that
about no just kidding but I just [ __ ]
with it right because it's it's
different adult [ __ ] you know it's
different so she told me he's like yeah
me and your dad were on acid when we
made you so because I have a crazy crazy
memory I always thought why do I have
this photographic memory so well and
then my mom said like because I was
expanding my brain when I was conceived
maybe right so
when it comes to the um the bad [ __ ]
that's why I always thought of the
consequence I was always it was always
too much for me like there's no going
back once I'm [ __ ] with this because
my dad he tried to do the nortanial
[ __ ] my dad is a [ __ ] nice person
it didn't last very long you know what I
mean my cousins do you ever have to have
the cards do they have that down there
you have to carry the car to the gang
you're in once you're once you get uh
hell no damn dude because they from
prison games out there oh because when I
was where I was from uh they give you
your water no yeah okay I can drink
that's it yeah the water yeah on here of
course yeah this is so sorry yeah that's
why I gave it to you I was like yo I'm
sorry dude for sure you can tweaking on
the camera
um
you know Thanksgiving what happens all
your cousins out of your age play
football you guys play [ __ ] football
you guys play something right well
that's what we did so on Thanksgiving my
grandma's got this property and I
remember my cousins they're all cool now
but one's actually correctional officers
no or no uh gang task the guy that talks
to the youth about gangs that's what my
cousin does now I remember I was about
12 years old this was like two years
older than me and it's not that they
were proud of it but they're like did
you get your [ __ ] and they were almost
like yeah look at my [ __ ] and I remember
I'm like
so I don't hang out with you guys after
so I'll hang out with you outside of
Grandma's a trading card yes [ __ ]
Saran you're like I won't say the names
but like Sereno around this this tattoos
blah blah blah and he had it he was
[ __ ] 14 I remember mother cousin was
17 the other one was 16. but he had he's
like look look at my [ __ ] my gangbanger
nfts that's exactly what I'm like yo
that's your authentication card I sound
like the police dude he was kind of like
proud I remember thinking but that's
what was me he's like
I can't do this man I was proud yeah but
see that's I love that some people love
that [ __ ] Bro unfortunately I did I
don't know because I tried playing
sports I did I tried to play in football
when I was like 12. I tried it bro it
just my mind wouldn't it's not for you
we can't have somebody yelling and
telling you to do seventh grade I did
not go to school the whole [ __ ] year
every day I went to school I ditched
yeah my seventh grade yeah also you
didn't really give a [ __ ] about
Authority at that point no I didn't care
about you're taking ass whooping by your
mom just ditch low-key yeah cause I
figured out like they didn't even figure
out low-key kind of I don't even think
the school was calling sometime but at
that point I was like [ __ ] it I mean I
went but but it caught up because then I
had to they kicked me out of LAUSD oh
[ __ ] all the schools yeah so then I had
to go like you know it's like an
alternative
[Music]
um
type [ __ ] got worse yeah it got worse
because that's where yeah it's breeding
grounds bro it's breeding grounds from
the back he's gonna teach you other [ __ ]
I come from for already from y a or they
coming from Camp already they haven't
been to jail already four or five times
[ __ ] like that yeah but um yeah that's
when she got got a little Wilder I think
the first time that I really went to
jail young it was for some wild [ __ ]
like we were smoking and um I lived on
112th and Normandy and we walked to
Imperium Vermont to look for somewhere
to smoking we well we went to go get
some blunts but we was looking for
somewhere to smoke so we came up with
this idea to jump this fence to a church
um I think it was like the weekend or it
was closed or maybe this was just the
parking lot maybe the church was a
little farther but we jumped the fence
and they had like six of them buses you
know like the
tour bus or some [ __ ] but the uh
like a bus like that like and um we got
in there and we smoked in there and said
we did that [ __ ] like two days and the
last day we was coming out they seen
some tools my homies and [ __ ] like boxes
of tools like I'm talking about the saws
the boxes of wrenches and [ __ ] to sell
yeah so they like [ __ ] it we gonna get
this [ __ ] and I'm like yeah y'all wild
we in the church bro cause my mother was
little she was religious it was like
Christians at first I think she was I
think she died of a Jehovah's Witness I
don't know why but
um
yeah it was wild so we took this [ __ ]
and before we even got I told him like
we should not this is Wild versus a
church they didn't care uh [ __ ] I was
with him so we did it we had to pick
that [ __ ] through the fence jump defense
get it we got like a block and a half
down we may be like another block and a
half from my house and and like it's
like a dip and they see some like um
some like uh some people right there in
their front yard and um they try to sell
it to him and I'm like why is y'all
trying to sell it to these people and
they like because they they was like I
think uh it was like Mexicans also like
oh they need these tools yeah and they
got the money or some [ __ ] and I'm like
well and look I just had like a
weird-ass feeling like bro we like one
more block and we at my house bro like
we go sell that [ __ ] could get sold
somewhere else I think I live next door
to a mechanic so like he lived next door
to me so I knew him but bro in the
middle of that [ __ ] I think he went in
there and called the police
the dude I was trying to sell it to I
think he knew where they where it came
from if he lived that close probably uh
because he waited and I'm like man what
the [ __ ] taking so long and they like oh
he getting the money he's getting the
money and I'm like bro we need to leave
leave and they're like nah he already
got the [ __ ] or whatever and then that's
when they come from both ways the
sheriffs
they like when they see him they're like
just come in the gate so they won't say
nothing and then they dumbass go in the
gate so I follow him but the whole time
them people getting us in the gate so we
can't run yeah can't go through the back
they got dogs everywhere like not in a
little friendly though they trapped your
ass yeah so we got a book but they only
took us to the police station that time
to Linux Sheriff's Station because I was
like I think 14 Maybe
so you didn't really have to go to jail
you just got booked I got booked but
that was the start this was the start of
[ __ ] everything first Domino yeah
because they put me on probation for
this I had to go to court for that [ __ ]
and all that they put me on probation or
some [ __ ] then they tried to take me to
uh prison this was like depressed well
not me to prison but like you know this
was before they're Beyond Scared
Straight [ __ ] oh and you're still 14. oh
yeah
to like a group of us kids to go see
prison but I'm I'm the type that bro I
already I'm on this [ __ ] I'm like if you
sitting us they took us to terminal
Island federal prison that [ __ ] is like
in San Pedro it's called terminal Island
yeah terminal Island federal prison you
gotta you gotta go over like this crazy
Bridge like real thin like it feel like
if you tip over it's over
um it's like it's on a rock
um basically it's like Alcatraz Loki um
out here I didn't know about this yeah
it's a federal prison it's like low-key
one I found out I think it's like
minimum custody or something but they
took us there to try to scare us
straight yeah none of that [ __ ] works it
doesn't work it doesn't work um because
look at my stepdad and all that [ __ ] he
used to like school me on like you see
this you don't even talk to this
[ __ ] you see this because he was
only gonna do it but anyway um
when I would see that [ __ ]
I'm looking at the prisoners and we go
visit I'm like
these fools are here for Life some of
these fools are never getting out and
they would have the kids come in and
they talk to him right I don't know why
it doesn't work because it really
[ __ ] should it's your actual future
and the guy's begging you like bro I was
you and now I can't [ __ ] go like it
should work but it never will because
it's someone trying to tell you
something and as a hard-headed kid
you're trying to tell me to do [ __ ] it's
not gonna ever work it has to be change
or tweaked some way it has something has
to happen you know it don't work what do
you think would change it I don't know I
got people that I try to do I try to
tell like don't I'll be seeing them like
on on certain Instagrams they trying to
say gangbang or something I'll tell them
like what is you doing bro you're a
little child these are like my little
nephews and certain type of people and
[ __ ] but it's crazy because it don't
matter what you tell them they still
gonna do what they do
I don't know bro I mean it's it's
because the the it's like the that [ __ ]
is like real popularized and I don't
know how it feel is like it's still like
really people like think it's really
something yeah when it's not when you're
gonna do everything for this [ __ ] wait
you know do everything all your time get
killed you can't even get buried you
gotta get a [ __ ] well it used to be
funerals but now let's go I mean uh uh
uh car washes you know they Gotta Throw
car washes to bury them now it's
gofundme's and [ __ ] probably now because
you know but it's just wild bro but I
don't know what it's gonna take bro I
think it's getting there though it's
getting a little better it really is
because people start they they caring
about money more which is a good thing
bro yeah because I what was it the thing
I should say as a kid like I'm trying to
make money I'm not trying to be in a
gang cause I had homies that were so
[ __ ] affiliate I was selling weed in
my homies
they're my homies you know what I mean
like I grew up as kids and I remember
the day you know what's crazy that I
remember because I'm on the opposite
side I'm on the one of the only kids of
my homies that was not down like nah bro
do your thing I'll beat your ass don't
talk [ __ ] to me like I can still [ __ ]
you up don't think because you're
getting used to that like I can't beat
you so when I remember the day I won't
say his name but I remember the day one
of my [ __ ] homies just like
came in with the Pressed Dickies and I
was like oh
all right so this weekend changed you
you did something this weekend that's
different and now then I said the last
next time I saw almost two years later
and he ran up on me and his [ __ ] was
busted clean open all his knuckles and
I'll just beat the [ __ ] out of some
scrap downstairs right now I'm like
uh uh I'm just smoking a blunt bro what
do you want like I was like because I
remember like it all come to me but I
know everyone my Town's small I'm Thomas
the guy with the fire weed and I'm nice
so nobody really [ __ ] with me
of course you get hit up of course
because you you're me I'm Brown I'm in
the brown of course but
it was easier for me to move around
everybody knowing that like he don't
[ __ ] with this gang [ __ ]
that was all it was growing up because
I I I'm saying because you know what
it's like to grow up around that and
you're obviously like I was already in
it I liked it the thing is I just don't
like uh
hitting I don't like hurting people I
can't just hurt [ __ ] I see my
homies like yo we're gonna beat the [ __ ]
out full like he didn't even do nothing
to you your homies got an altercation
you're gonna jump him that was my thing
is it's like I remember my friend was
like yo help me fight this guy I'm like
what'd you do like so you're wrong I
ain't helping you fight this guy
okay that was my thing like you're wrong
I ain't gonna be the bad guy for you I
don't think I'm the bad guy I always say
if this is a movie are you the bad guy
and that's how it goes so that was my
thing of why I stayed away from all of
it I mean I was involved in the streets
but I would never know uh like
scandalous person like I wasn't a bad no
sorry I didn't mean to say it like no
not no no not you saying that I'm just
saying like me I'm just saying that you
didn't say that I'm just saying like I
wasn't a bad net that's why I'm still
around like I wasn't a bad individual I
never really did
I I never really did dirt like when I
was younger I probably did them houses
that when I was young some of them
people probably was innocent people I
probably paid my karma in debt so that
[ __ ] I'm pretty sure but like I never
really did know [ __ ] to innocent people
I never like prayed on the week targeted
oh yeah I just never did stupid [ __ ]
like period even when I got even when it
got worse
15 16 17 18. I still never did nothing
bad I mean not nothing like I never did
no wild [ __ ] never yeah and I don't mean
like all gangsters are piece of [ __ ]
because I know a lot of gang bangers
that are dope as [ __ ] they just happen
to be super Affiliated and they're good
people try to mind we've had them on
here exactly we've had a lot of them on
here they're good [ __ ] people
it's just I meant like that culture that
environment I I know one day I might
have to do something stupid or do
something unjustified in my house oh no
yeah for sure that's what I meant I
don't mean like no no lady no not you no
I never said you said that oh no no like
I wasn't a type I never I mean games
nothing horrible like I mean I did some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
did you like from the time like from 12
through like 19 like you're saying was
that like a like a spiral was it like
horrible or were you kind of just still
chilling now even though you're all
wrapped up in it
because at first like I wouldn't even
like like I wouldn't even from this set
yet like younger like 12 13 14. so I was
just running wild like doing kitchen no
this wasn't kitchen at this time like
like 11 and [ __ ] oh that's the kid
should stop 12 [ __ ] that [ __ ] started
getting real like people start getting
shot we was getting shot at I have
people friends dying and [ __ ] but um
it was just
damn I could I don't know what the [ __ ]
was I just saying you're good you were
saying was it like my question was like
was it a horrible downward spiral
through oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was
horrible because I wasted a lot of damn
time doing a lot of stupid [ __ ] I sat
around what I didn't understand was if
the whole point of me being in the
streets then I should be getting [ __ ]
money and I'm a juvenile I should be
running up a bag but I wasn't doing that
that was that's what I don't understand
now as a reckless for free yeah like
real Reckless like three doing anything
you know just wild going to jail ready
to start anything anywhere looking at
everybody's stupid I was wearing the
dickies with the chucks with the laces
I've been I was on that [ __ ] white
t-shirts we was wearing pro clubs all
that [ __ ] inside out it was yeah it was
bad because it just started getting like
worser than the um the drinking the
smoking the hanging out every day but I
still went to school through the mirrors
though still did oh [ __ ] your mom made
you huh no she was dead already oh [ __ ]
she died when I was 14. no [ __ ] oh yeah
I forgot to get into that yeah she died
who'd you live with that after that well
they well my sister because my grandma
like I said my grandmother had bought
property on 79th and Figueroa [ __ ] it
was like a friend house and it was like
one two three it was like a four unit
apartment in the back but she never
rented it out to nobody it was just for
um like the family um
so like my grandmother had died my mama
died but my grand my uh Uncle still had
the um the property so I basically went
over there we was living on 112th and
Normandy
um these are like 63 but one day
everybody came over it was weird like
people that don't even come over that
she really don't even talk to me she
talked to him but they just ain't been
to her house and then everybody came
over and then the next morning my niece
woke up and she was dead in the bed they
came over because she was sick no I'm
saying like everybody you know how
people come to your grandmother house
like your cousins uh they bring their
friends that know your grandma or
something so it's kind of like a
kickback then when they leave your niece
stay your cousin stay when they woke up
in the morning they slept on the floor
so I guess when they went to sleep you
know they just went in there because I
had a room me and my brother so she was
already in the room when we was outside
she had one in her room so she I guess
she went in there and had a stroke
in our sleep
and by the time we uh found out it was
way too late she was already like cold
kind of like you know like that her body
fluids came out I'm like oh man that's
terrible you know those are 14 December
like like December 3rd I think 20 I mean
2008
[ __ ] damn so now how alone are you
feeling now after that it was horrible
bro because you got to think like
I mean we wasn't rich but we always had
a house room you know the food
refrigerator teeth we always had our own
[ __ ] so now that [ __ ] is over with
pretty much oh yeah huh [ __ ] done like I
mean how many kids live with you at this
point how many people your little
brother you your uncle your sisters no
no no no no no no
um at that time when my mother died it
was just me her my older sister one of
my older sisters not a twin oh yeah I
forgot my my mama had
she had five because she had another
sister I forgot but it was just me her
it was it was Maisha my mama and my
brother and me so it was four people in
the house and we lived in an apartment
on 112th in Normandy and my uncle used
to manage these apartments that was a
horrible area too that was bad
yeah
they didn't even have a a police station
Sheriff's with his sheriffs was from
Linux so it wasn't really no Patrol over
there now it's a sheriff station but it
was bad but she died in there though yo
and um we had to call the uh corner with
an ambulance I think they caught the
corner or something it was horrible
though so it went I would have to go to
my sister house at first but she already
got kids
it's got a husband so I'm 14 that [ __ ]
not gonna work no he trying to tell her
that me and my brother is playing
fighting and all types of [ __ ] so that's
when I went to my sister house on 79th
and he ran away
your brother did yeah
wait he's younger than you a year
younger did he come back eventually he
was going for a minute damn I been in
like four years what the [ __ ] for years
he did yeah he went to people he knew I
guess heard he just he just did I think
I was at one point I seen him doing some
[ __ ] like traveling just doing I think
he was working and traveling or some
[ __ ] I don't know he didn't come back
yeah well you guys basically don't have
anybody assigned to you at that point
you're on like low-key if we got my
sisters and them but at the same time
it's like it's you know they going
through the loss today Mama it just
saying it wasn't the same bro it was it
was basically like low kiwi was on her
own yeah eventually it sounds like so he
ran away one day he was supposed to go
to school he left just never came back
he never told you [ __ ] no he didn't tell
me damn you probably knew I was going to
stop him or tell them to stop him and do
something I don't know probably you tell
nobody just left
I mean I eventually like uh
um got into contact with him took like a
year and a half two years
what the [ __ ] you couldn't take it I
guess right away
got it right away
damn bro that's [ __ ] scary My Little
Brother Martin ran away for two and a
half years too
out and about just on the Run cops
looking for everything and I remember I
[ __ ] the day he called I was in
college and he called me I'm like yo
who's Martin like what the [ __ ] I was
like my brother I'm like
what like I finally talked to after
Years bro yeah I bet him out of park and
we uh we had smoked this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you wouldn't met him yeah this was like
a year or two years in like a year and a
half or two years but he ran away and
I'm like what are you doing and he
looked at kind of bad but I didn't have
money like that so I couldn't give him I
think I left I got him the rest of the
weed I had or something ah [ __ ] and then
just left but yeah he ran away he was
living with my sister at first like he
stayed with her I left he stayed with
her he I went to the other sister's
house
um but he ran away yeah
then come back to he was grown I'm
saying that's like the most Brave thing
I ever heard of a little boy like not
done doing my own because we was we was
already I mean like we at 12 we was
already on the bus like my mom used to
let us catch the bus so he was already
going maybe to like the yeah
catch the bus to the movie theater when
it was Magic Johnson theater on Crenshaw
and King so he was already doing that
[ __ ] but you ever see the movie Four
Brothers yeah I've seen this man that's
never seen it no uh Mark Wahlberg this
is damn near Chinese right yeah yeah the
four adopted Brothers come the mom dies
Andre 3000. damn I'm listening now I
think I've seen the I think seeing a
piece of it because I know that Mark
Wahl version I think yeah it was wild
bro it was just it was just like damn
you don't got nothing else but I always
told myself after she died I have to
finish school because that's always what
she kept saying is to do go to school go
to school go to school so that's what
made me just keep going to school but
every day I was still trying to get in I
mean get in the [ __ ] but not get in the
[ __ ] but I was still getting
[ __ ] so but I still managed to make
it through school and you finish High
School yeah damn I graduated
from the alternative school yeah it was
a Hawthorne Academy or some [ __ ] like
that
that's dope dude did you ever try
College
I did like the uh what's the like the
little trade [ __ ] I only did that to try
to get off probation worst thing I did
because I still got [ __ ] student
loans oh no what are you trying to do
what was it uh 18 the school was ATC it
was like telecommunications so it's
basically like installing the um
I tried it for a minute but my head just
wasn't there nothing was I just did it
really to get because I was um on
probation
and they was like you gotta go do
something yeah damn dude well yeah no
you didn't mention that you basically on
your own since 14. that makes a lot more
sense now well yeah I mean
um realistically yeah
and still got through school a lot of
kids would have really yeah I mean I
still had that property they didn't sell
that property to a few years later so I
still but it was basically like I was on
my own my sister wasn't like you know
she was still drinking she had her own
kids like that was the spot like the
party spot you feel me so basically I
Gotta Wait today get done all the
partying and go to sleep or some [ __ ]
like that yeah
Kickback out stuff yeah it was horrible
bro for a long time I ain't gonna lie to
you but I just kept pushing and [ __ ]
are you close to your brothers and
sisters still
um I mean I talked to my brother he just
he would move to San Diego though so so
he must be in his 50s no no no not the
yeah the older brother is I don't really
talk I mean I talk to them but I ain't I
ain't really um close to him close to
him right now like that oh okay so
that's why I was wondering because
that's such a my other brother though
the one I got adopted with I still talk
to him nice nice where'd you live uh you
moved to San Diego oh that's where you
said San Diego good [ __ ] man
what does he do
[ __ ] I don't know
I I I'm really not these I like armed
security or some [ __ ] right now oh damn
he was Rent-A-Center but I think he left
that [ __ ] like he was the manager of
Rent-A-Center or something nice man that
ain't nice no that's dope anytime you
have a job that's steady good [ __ ] you
live in San Diego you live insane no he
was the manager like sent uh
Rent-A-Center out here but that [ __ ] is
horrible I think you have to work every
day open and close it well I mean when
you have a job I think because that's
what I was doing I was doing Pizza [ __ ]
I had job multiple jobs my whole life
and I I hated this [ __ ] but once you
don't have a job and you're like yeah
we're gonna pay rent like and that
steady job was dope it's worse that's
how I thought about it I didn't I didn't
learn about a real I didn't know what a
real job was into 22.
that's the type of people that I was
around yeah I saw weed my whole life
yeah I was doing you know streets like I
was doing [ __ ] like you know here we
here and there you know the little
[ __ ] maybe little robberies but I
wasn't doing nothing to no regular
people but not like that just it was a
little [ __ ] here and there but um I
started doing the other [ __ ] get money
but
22 or something I found out what a job
was would you get what'd you do uh UPS
driver number oh you're the helper for
the seasonal you know what the job is
for real now and and I was crazy because
I seen somebody and I'm like man how the
[ __ ] they get a job here and then I
found out it was seasonal and I'm like
oh well I can get this [ __ ] and then I
tried and I got it and I wouldn't work
and I picked Hollywood the Hollywood
division because I thought I was gonna
get more hours or something but that was
bad bro bad apartment buildings and [ __ ]
yeah the heels deep in there a lot of
[ __ ] yeah it was crazy all the worst bro
seven floor Apartments you gotta go
right here right here right here down
through this one down it was horrible
but it made me like appreciate gay
people get paid too yeah but before that
I didn't did like the move-in [ __ ] with
my uncle like he oh you did performance
so no I didn't move people [ __ ] out the
apartments I always dish like that cut
trees and [ __ ] like that like my mother
she made us clean up rearrange the room
um every two weeks or something yeah
yeah no we have to clean up washed our
clothes at 10 we started doing that oh
man you got structure and [ __ ] too so
that I think that's how you finish
school yeah so about 14 we was already
like we knew how to catch the bus
anywhere like full grown man at that
point low-key I got a 14 year old I want
I'm trying to get her to catch the bus
I'm learning how to just be response
like you don't know which bus you gotta
[ __ ] figure it out you might have to
ask the bus driver you might have to go
to the website you might have to Google
this [ __ ] like I need you to I used to
have it out they used to have them
things too back then I think they still
got them but we used to get those then
we learned the uh the route book oh yeah
so the routes and [ __ ] when you did
movies you have to use the TomTom guides
remember the TomTom map oh yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] before navigations came out oh man
I remember trying to read a map I used
to do moving my whole family does moving
like
three of my my dad my uncle my cousin my
other Uncle all own different movie
companies so that's what we've been
doing our whole life and uh those Maps
man I never felt more dumb in my whole
life trying to figure out where I am on
a map I
I don't know I was a little kid I hated
that [ __ ] so I know what you're saying
you didn't have like a steady job you're
clocking in every day every day but
you're cutting trees you're doing moving
[ __ ] you still work yeah I was I mean I
was yeah I was doing that I mean when we
was kids we was doing all type of [ __ ]
like we was when we was on 53rd you know
my homeboy was selling candy I was going
to him do that we even had like jobs
um
uh water new people grass on the Block
as a kid we was doing that like all old
people huh yeah you know I'm saying who
doesn't water like the duplexes and [ __ ]
we used to go find the people that
probably seen us or know who we are some
knock on these people door and then get
like a a a a job I think I've been had a
job at the beach shop on 53rd for a
minute yeah it sounds a success yeah bro
I'm just cleaning up and [ __ ] that's
when I was young though but you still
sounds like you had that at the out to
go get it you're not just like we're
like damn when I got [ __ ] yeah but when
I got to like
that that 14 and 15. I didn't even know
what that [ __ ] was a real job I didn't
even want to work probably
I get it too I would sell a weed packs I
mean as soon as I graduated when the
pack started but I still had to get a
job to maintain like oh that's how I pay
my rent because I live in a small town
you know what I mean you still don't
want to get your door kicked in or
enough [ __ ] or to hit you yeah
or enough to do that exactly or the
people to like sell enough packs to
where it's like hey fool who is this for
like oh I always stood under like 20. so
I wasn't like oh you're the man bringing
it back like no I'm bringing in 20 a
fire which worth more than your 50 which
is but you know what I mean like when it
comes to the weed [ __ ] I if I live in a
gang town in a meth town they don't
really care about the weed man you know
what I mean it's more about who's got
[ __ ] Chris who's got bricks of it so
I never really had to worry about
gang [ __ ] and plus like I said everybody
knew who I was and I'm just like the
nice dude that sold packs but
when it comes to the the work ethic
thing I think you're saying you didn't
really wasn't about you I think he was
man I mean from what you're telling me
having that many jobs let me just trying
to make money and get [ __ ] done and
you're not afraid to work so that's
pretty dope I I feel and you started
this whole episode off with
you are doing the dishwasher the head
dishwasher [ __ ] and then you're like I
don't even know what YouTube was so it
sounds like you just you just at another
stage of your life where like now this
is gonna work because this YouTube [ __ ]
you're like I'm this is what pays my
bills this is what I do I don't even
clock in no more yeah no I've been stuck
right yeah so I was working so for
everyone out there that's because you
know like you probably have younger
siblings or cousins or friends the
friends that look up and like damn well
you really make YouTube videos get paid
for that and they look like that's a
real job
yeah no it's a yeah yeah it's a real job
um yeah um I I don't have to go to a
real job I just sit in the house I uh
get my mind right take something for
7.4 seconds every day do a few videos
and yeah I mean I'm not living that bad
no I think it's cool I think it's great
because what I'm saying like
my girl's little my girl's friend's son
always asks like so for YouTube so if I
made a channel and I could do he's like
11 like if I made a channel how much
money could I make potentially off of
them oh a lot because kids are looking
at it like it is a real career though
yeah they can make a lot they need to do
it I tell everybody with kids make tell
your kids y'all need to make like a
YouTube channel
you like man there's money in there it's
money first though yeah I was doing I
wasn't even caring about the money at
first that first time you got monetized
those that's what that it took like two
and a half months to get money damn
that's it yeah oh you were doing a lot
of [ __ ] there yeah that's fast as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm doing like five videos
a day outside I'm sitting outside
uploading five videos a day I was
recording five videos editing them and
uploading them like the next day or some
[ __ ] like that that was what like two
years ago yeah I started like the first
time I uploaded a video
maybe like June of 2019 are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me yeah that was just the first
time I ever I sat across the street this
is from it was this it's this restaurant
called like Faith and Flower okay so
before we started talking we were
talking about you lived across the
street from me yeah at this whole time
we figured it out as I was making my
first story times he was making his
first videos across the street in front
of my building yeah on the back or the
side yeah the side of the building and
thing is I lived in the apartment in the
back I was overlooking that part so I
was literally right above your that's
probably why nobody wasn't complaining
like that I remember that yeah I got so
many smoking points they used to
Sometimes they used to uh uh a lot they
used to they they used to trip some of
the security guards oh yeah dude the
suits yeah but some used to be like man
I guess [ __ ] it he's just gonna keep
coming every day then I learned to just
sit behind the camera because it's a
camera at first I used to sit on the
side like right here so maybe I'm like
[ __ ] they see me that's crazy so now sit
behind camera and I was good yeah my
room was above that little part where
they where the security is at isn't that
a trip that's where the story time
started in that room that's [ __ ]
ironic wow so that's that's crazy you
started doing your reaction I got to be
honest that is fast bro I used to hold a
phone
it was crazy I was doing reactions out
there bro sitting on the ground outside
like people walking by I know I was like
what is he doing what are you talking
about what the [ __ ] is he doing yeah is
he tweaking oh hell no I got I got uh
three shirts with a with a with a pillow
inside of a pillowcase like taped
sideways and I walk outside with it like
this when I get out there I sit on it
because I tried I said out there it was
with just nothing at first but then my
ass started hurting yeah and I'm like
I'm gonna get hemorrhoids doing this
[ __ ] so I had to take something
yeah because you couldn't smoke no my
girl trip
Decor so she was like that [ __ ] make it
stink and all that and I'm like oh this
is wild but um I guess I'll sit outside
yeah I had a choice at first I had to
show her like why I'm I'm a um this [ __ ]
gonna pop watch and uh y'all sit out
there every day in front of that
apartment on the side of the apartment
and smoke like over there
no I'm pretty sure she believed in me
but she's just like it just wasn't real
enough for her to be like whoa just go
in the bathroom yeah
and uh I sat out there every day after I
get off work after I go in there and um
I go to take a shower roll like three or
four blunts have my uh [ __ ] go out there
sit down and I did about three or four
videos every day
yeah until that [ __ ] happened into that
uh that that that uh pandemic [ __ ]
happened oh bro when that [ __ ] happened
um I was working that whole time I had
worked all type of odd kitchen jobs
Saddle Ranch Teo uh
highlight room
um all these kitchen jobs I had worked
because I was kept bouncing around for
more money closer because everywhere I
worked was like two hours on the bus oh
[ __ ] but I did it I didn't have no
choice Saddle Ranch I'm there
uh Martins in uh Los Felix was my first
job uh I mean Atwater Village it's this
[ __ ] called uh Martins
it was like top seven on Yelp or
something it was a restaurant like a
little uh restaurant and um somebody got
me a job they're dishwashing you know I
was like [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna do it
you're gonna give me a job and um I went
PM Chef it was just slow uh it was just
um mandatory couldn't even speak English
or nothing
uh I think it was a Pisa
but
I still learned everything like
everything he taught me everything
he did just like speaking in the uh yeah
like yeah how many times he snapped at
you and then yeah
yeah
so you learned all that [ __ ] I was doing
that [ __ ] yeah
so damn okay so I I just I I love I love
to hear it man because this I probably
saw your my favorite stories from the
podcast him starting his channel because
he can't smoke underneath dope is the
oldest window that [ __ ] is crazy to me
yo I got so many smoking complaints and
so many times I would say I don't know I
would say like I don't even [ __ ]
smoke blunts how many times I would say
like I don't even smoke tobacco it
probably was that's telling you it was a
dog park nobody uses dog park because
they use my dog part it was a dog park
behind my apartment yeah at the Apex it
was it was crazy and nobody went to this
dog park and it was like a cut right
here with a parking garage at exactly in
a bar gate where you could see the cars
but nobody really can't really go nobody
really come out that door really it's
like emergency door like by a pool maybe
nobody gonna lived in front of the pool
remember I know exactly what you're
talking about
bra set there every day smoked every day
that is [ __ ] the first two three
weeks it was kind of like okay with the
security guards might come they were
cool though not at first the little them
soups they was coming they talked about
the little Max to do was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] people
like the the maintenance people trying
to tell me something I'm like bro you
haven't been [ __ ] really like just go
clean up like yeah man just leave me
good trust me you trust me I'm good I'm
just not doing nothing bro I'm just
smoking I don't steal I live across the
street I used to you know I used to do I
used to hold my key fob when that when
people look at me and I used to do this
yeah that's right live here [ __ ] yeah
not but they I don't think they knew I
lit it but yeah that probably was me
getting you to complaint [ __ ] no I'm
thinking of it now like I gotta go back
and watch one of your videos just so I
could see my [ __ ] window above you no
they gonna show the window it only show
that that I was strategic I didn't show
[ __ ] I just said that brick wall I know
exactly what yeah but it's like a it's
like a dog park a little the side where
to uh it's like the parking the little
emergency door I know you could go up to
a pool upstairs one upstairs is the pool
where I was at like you can hear it
sometime because sometimes move because
the water either the sprinklers or the
people who want water in the grass right
there needs to come over bro that was
[ __ ] but I'm like sick you're in that
little hall right by the security door
and then if you go out there's the
across the streets that fit them that
[ __ ] fashion school right there
man this is a trip so I know we talked
about it earlier but yeah I really
really just pinpointed like you're right
below
yeah I used to live right by Ralphs I
was in Ralph's every day yeah let's half
a block away because it's right right
yeah damn
we're like I'm sorry this is too much
for me right now that's [ __ ] you know
how many times I almost got kicked out
four times
and twice I'm like I don't smoke [ __ ]
Blunts and that was the one thing like
it suppose my blunts out here it's not
me that's all it takes there was a
question every mother Isis I was getting
the hell of slabs of oil like hash at
the time and all my friends would bring
in the pizza boxes so I'd have how many
friends a day coming over pizza boxes
and [ __ ] to show me [ __ ] and then it got
to the point where they started asking
people to look into everything when they
come into my room which is not true
you're not allowed to do that [ __ ] and I
talked to the management he didn't do it
no more but that's the [ __ ] I
was saying he's probably the fool that
was like what the [ __ ] I stopped for
like two weeks at one point just two
weeks because it was it was getting kind
of like every day that it was coming it
was her it was him the chick was okay
yeah but all of them still had to come I
mean I know it's their job yeah they
have to they have somebody sent them so
I wouldn't like the chick with the slick
back hair the kind of chunky chicken
enough of none of the um the like
security guards that came but I stopped
for two weeks but I went right back
I used to edit when I go back edit the
videos
going the house upload videos yeah until
I got the 10 000 subscribers then I told
her Hey look check this out 10 000
subscribers people are starting to look
at me I'm feeling paranoid I'm not about
to be sitting right here if anybody come
I'm kind of cornered like what I'm gonna
do just shoot crazy into like it's wild
like what I'm cornered off I don't want
to do it here this is you are quartered
and if somebody wants to pull up
you get [ __ ] blasted in this hallway
it's just a hallway and you gotta run
out to the street and if you don't and
that was crazy too because they could
just come from right here and I don't
even see him
yep they you do you wouldn't even see
them that's a thing were you ever live
streaming or you were just doing the
straight videos uh I didn't live stream
but I never showed I just showed the
wall I know it's just the wall That's
Why They Call Me homeless milk I was
like okay
luxury condo yeah I used to live on an
18th floor apartment like 3 400 rent bro
before YouTube like that's even before I
started YouTube I started YouTube there
so yeah I was already had your [ __ ]
together pre YouTube yeah I think so but
yeah Corona when that pandemic [ __ ]
happened I mean when I hit 10 000
subscribers I told her like check I
can't be out here no more the hell then
I went to the bathroom and I started
doing them in there for the meanwhile
yeah and then to the balcony with well
we've moved because that one didn't have
a balcony them just got big ass Windows
they don't have balconies and um and
they move down the street but then we
[ __ ] up because we moved there and the
train right there and at first I'm like
okay that ain't gonna be no big thing it
might come one every oh no whenever that
[ __ ] did not stop it was ring
and then it before it even come you know
I make that noise yep we had a train
ring and then when they come ring ring
and they never stopped and that was hard
on like doing YouTube out there that
[ __ ] was crazy we built the whole
warehouse and then realized oh there's a
train oh that goes right past here oh
yeah oh dude and it never stopped when
you walked in did you see our old set
the old walls that were out there yeah
we used to film out there and there'd be
times where we'd have to just
it'd be nervous I'll be like even even
on a balcony like that people think it's
just good because it's the view but that
[ __ ] is hard on me it's horrible like
I'd be kind of nervous when you're in a
flow too I don't know yeah it's not hard
you need to be a little Studio setup
that you can try like that's what I'm
gonna get right now and at least it's up
but like cause they tripping on the
balcony smoking where I'm at right now
damn that's annoying dude you're smoking
outside yeah but I'm going hard Loki and
then I gotta think like the people that
have been living there before me they
got my Juliet window they probably mad I
got the balcony some of them could be
mad but then overall you got to think
like [ __ ] if they penis amount of rent
they got that Juliet window they've been
used to sitting right there without
smoking the apartment no smoking which
is Goofy because I think they should
make one side like because they know
everybody smoke yeah or they should have
some type of but yes I ain't tripping so
but they ain't tripping on me yet but
they didn't send letters out standing on
the floor oh yeah General letters yeah
yo they say an eviction though the other
apartments just saying like if you got
caught you just have to pay like a
little fine or something now now that I
moved I could I never even talked about
it my last apartment you know how many
times they would come to my [ __ ] door
because I was I was smoking but never
when they would show up so randomly I
would always be like open the door I'm
like I ain't even smoking because I
wasn't smoking yet but I I smoked that
place out with zip joints but now I can
say because I moved that girl whoa Vicky
that that girl that's on Instagram she
was my [ __ ] she lived right next to me I
never told anybody this in case they
knew where she lived but she lived right
there and she would box that [ __ ] went
backwards whoever she was with and it
would always come to me bro so another
person making videos over here getting
me [ __ ] blood smoking charges and
[ __ ] I think that story of him I can't
believe that that was you yeah I'm not
lying no no the way you say it because I
know exactly what I lived at the Apex
you go through the like you know
everything in there is like you gotta
walk through [ __ ] you come through the
elevator go through the parking they got
the big dog park go to the dog park
cross the street and I used to set my
eyes right there I know exactly where
you're at because there are people from
Vietnam used to always smoke bowls there
like a lot of people would sit there and
smoke bowls on lunch and [ __ ] when they
would go to school because it's a
perfect a hallway for smoking weed if
there's no air coming in you can light a
blunt you can light a bowl and no one
really comes down there and lets you
know that's there and it's deep off the
sidewalk yeah it's hot yeah it was
perfect I told her no
[Music]
this [ __ ] is horrible it's not fun to be
talking outside on camera like because
you're looking at the camera I mean you
don't know what's I mean yeah like I
can't maybe people if you do vlogs maybe
but I still I I'm me just do what's
doing and I was still beginning on
Cameron's period so I was a little
some people walk by bro I'll stop oh
yeah yeah wait and then like do it again
but the first video I did it at a bus
stop by to buy a restaurant down on 9th
and flower
oh [ __ ] I hope it's called faithful
Faith and Flower that's a restaurant
right yeah yeah I try to go there but
they didn't have reservation yeah
um yeah I did it right because they got
the the bus stop right there but you
could sit further down I just did it
real quick smoke did a video it didn't
just went from there and then ten
thousand hit and then yeah and your fan
base is like super active like you're
pretty you kind of like him in the sense
that you're always talking to them and
then the chats and [ __ ] right yeah yeah
I'll be on live I talked to all of them
I talked to the trolls to whoever the
yeah I just do this but get out and I
kick him out of the channel there's
nothing there's no room oh they love
they're live because I just talk [ __ ] to
whoever in there when I'm on there like
I don't care there was a time where I
was like yeah [ __ ] off but now it's more
of like
my time's valuable I'm not going to
waste it on [ __ ] that are rude
you're gonna get out of the chat hey by
the way positive guy what's up because
at the point there's at a point where
I'm like there's so many people in the
chair I'm like bro you're taken away
from other people get out but sometimes
it's funny yeah sometimes I'm like yeah
I haven't been I mean I'm doing that
[ __ ] though because they've been they've
been chirping on that um oh your live
streams on the balcony
oh yeah and I wouldn't be live streaming
on the balcony especially people on the
trains see what buildings next to you
like I kind of know what floor you live
on I I can't do it I mean I showed it I
mean I showed a view oh then you're fine
then I ain't worried I wasn't worried
about that I've been doing that it's
third balcony I mean no the second one
two you're the second balcony sure
um I shouldn't have did that maybe I
won't do it at the next one don't do the
next one yeah but it's a beautiful view
yeah no training I probably got more
views off the view you know like that
helps right
it might but I didn't got views in
shitty areas I mean by that wall it's
literally one it's just a nice view
color
I like to bring I like to bring the view
if I could yeah so if they tripping off
the weed I've been out there with a pen
you're gonna be like a petty punch and
say something about the pen you got to
get some pen companies though [ __ ]
yeah I've been up I've been off a pen um
doing the videos on the balcony still
damn I'm gonna bring you the view as
long as I can do it so everywhere I move
I try to get a view even if it's in a
room like because the windows that we
get is like Florida ceiling type [ __ ]
yeah yeah the double wall is kind of
okay yeah I got that that [ __ ] scares me
my new spot I got a sick for you I just
can't show people show up as spots and
[ __ ] oh you can't even you can't even
show the amenities oh hell no people
recognize it you can't can't even show
your kitchen counter I mean the
countertops because I could tell you
what apartment I know exactly me and my
girl didn't tour like when we first
started moving in these apartments they
would you know you could go tour them oh
yeah we didn't tour it every apartment
every rapper that posts in the [ __ ]
luxury apartment I know where you're at
every time I live next to these famous
every time people at the defense they
live right down like like the Vicky girl
like I was saying I went
if you lived at the DaVinci's it was
more than her no no it was recently
right here and when I lived in Glendale
I lived in the brand and there's a like
the top like the big spots or whatever
but I wanted to move out there I did um
I live in Burbank but glendale's nice as
hell it's just expensive for no reason
everywhere I heard yeah for expensive
it's fun for no reason like right now I
live in a it's dope the view is crazy
but I can't show that view [ __ ]
will be in the lobby and [ __ ] I mean you
could kind of show The View kind of nah
people are good you could low-key pit
you could you could put some some
decorations at the bottom of the thing
you could try some I mean I could have
did something a little better but not
people Gonna Know gonna know exactly
you're from L.A you know if I show you a
mountain and you see what's on the
mountains
very honest with you low-key if I never
moved in that apartment and been on that
balcony I maybe couldn't have told you
where that view was from that balcony
that's the thing too you got to be from
like right now yeah no because I I have
posted certain parts of my last
apartment everyone had lived in Glendale
at the brand and [ __ ] like do
you live in Glendale damn [ __ ] I just
posted the inside of my [ __ ]
apartment somebody already like you said
the amenity like like all that oh you
live at the brand or you live at and
they said the other next Michael it's
bad cause you can just go Google it man
I posted a picture of my kids on
Halloween I didn't even think nothing of
it like I normally don't post my kids a
lot so one of the fans wrote them in hey
I could tell your kid goes to this
school because the letters on her pants
yeah and I was like didn't even dawn on
me that she even had letters on her
pants first off you're Googling [ __ ] bro
yeah exactly it's kind of like bro be
Googling it Google okay all right let's
delete the [ __ ] pig but Jesus Christ
that's weird yeah I get if they're wrong
just be safe like I can tell that's why
I just I mean not even like bad [ __ ]
like I also don't want like a bunch of
people just showing up that's just
period yeah I don't think the next one I
would do that yeah I don't just keep it
cool and that's the thing is like I like
you it's like damn I wish I could
headed to this background yeah because
it's dope at night but it's okay
um real quick before uh we we start
keeping that here I want to ask you a
little segment we have here and Marty
switched it up and did a whole fresh
segment for you and this is called who
were you in the 90s so you're a couple
years younger than us but still you grew
up in the [ __ ] 90s like 90s to 2000s
you remember that [ __ ] so imagine you're
in the 90s that kid what would he pick
out of these two choices and that's the
little segment all right so not now
knowing what you know but like as a kid
in real time in the 90s real time all
right Marty take it away La Edition La
Edition we did we've only you've only
went to the Chicago Edition yeah la
Edition usually just normal yeah it's
usually like standard [ __ ] that
everybody experienced when we did 90s
dilation all right so off top in 90s
this is meant to be like rapid fire Kobe
or Shaq bigger fan of Kobe okay all
right all right that's an e I'm sorry
Shaq but that's easy I mean okay that's
the I mean but I ain't gonna lie to you
it's Kobe yeah sure maybe it was the one
you guys had such a [ __ ] like they
were such just Champions back then like
and especially when he left I was I was
uh oh with Jack left yeah that's
different I hope you've been out here I
mean you know all that time yeah I moved
down here the year he retired and I
remember when Kobe retired the I looked
at the Met obviously you lived there too
all the [ __ ] oh my God I could barely
walk outside there was so many [ __ ]
you couldn't even drive nothing dude no
so you lived there when on off topic so
you lived there when the Donald Trump
was running for president they started
doing protest yeah remember the protest
started in my parking lot there was a
time I had a meeting at the convention
center and I couldn't drive and I
couldn't walk because it was raining and
I missed my whole meeting because there
were so many protesters outside they
were outside your window too then it was
everywhere it was like Hey I used to
live by where they had that Hibachi
trucks get my [ __ ] nerves I know
exactly what truck you're talking it was
like a million people at this truck like
before damn you live so close to people
wow I'm like God damn I charged that
[ __ ] with him good I never tried it
because I was like no there's no way
it's that good you have a restaurant all
right no they got one now oh so there it
is everybody they pushed a little a
little uh Taco a little restaurant out
the way and they got a little thing
across from L.A live but I know exactly
what you're talking about right there
next to like the new weed store that's
in there now you see that or like it's
like a smoke shop or something yeah it's
like and it's uh it might be a Wii shop
right there I think I think so it's
across the street from like the little
restaurants like Yard House yeah exactly
yeah where the car wash it's a car wash
on there right there yeah and then a
little parking lot right there yeah
exactly I used to work right there at
the hotel that [ __ ] was wild oh the the
one they always paint the back of yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] all right Dad you lived
next door to where you worked yeah
that's crazy because when I worked there
I didn't live there but as I'm as I
worked there we moved there so like it
was people mad because during the 30
minute break I could go home
um
two hour [ __ ] bus ride to walking
across today walking
they always paint the crazy [ __ ] and I
used to live at the [ __ ] man this is
a trip man yeah yeah two different
[ __ ] gave me smoking charges
all right sorry on to the next thing you
ready go for it Marty boys in the hood
or Menace
boys in the hood I think it resonates
more to me this Society was so sad yeah
oh that is they're both pretty [ __ ]
yeah but I just like boys I think I
don't know why but Minnesota Society was
dope that's a good movie man yeah uh Ice
Cube or iced tea of course I was cute
well I don't even think I really I don't
I can't even name like no songs iced tea
like ice tea I know more if iced tea has
uh as a cop on TV yeah
victims
yeah I mean now he's the copper TV
yeah he's a special victim
oh for sure leprechaun of the hood I
think at one name I I could name one
song he did six in the morning or
something colors
cop killer that's all I know I feel bad
maybe I should go back and listen some
more I see because he's hard yeah I mean
those songs I know yeah [ __ ] hard but
I was too young I think I was too young
for iced tea to be like prevalent in my
life I was already on ice cubes Ice Cube
Friday watching everything his Ice Cube
was my childhood more were you mainly on
like West Coast [ __ ] growing up or did
you like not hell no I listen more to
Boosie Webbie oh [ __ ] like that I
wouldn't really I was listening to Lil
Wayne
um
whatever you little Boosie uh that's
when Mike Jones I was still that's like
when he hit them four or five songs
around that time Plies
um
no I wasn't even really listening to
Western music like deep southern hip-hop
damn growing up where you grew up and
you're not even listening to the music
from that I mean really no music like
that I mean it wasn't West Coast music
no I mean it wasn't really none that I
was listening to I mean it probably was
like
four years it could have been like what
Dr Dre with the Eminem and [ __ ] yeah
explosive and you're born like 94 right
not 933 yeah so yeah I guess so by the
time you really hit music
yeah I was listening I listened to old
music too still like I still I was
listening to Mobb Deep some [ __ ] like uh
Ice Cube all the old west side
connection yeah
um [ __ ] like that bro you wouldn't
really know yes I don't know the radio
anymore like my my sister's name when
that they was growing up I mean when I
was growing up they listened to a lot of
Blues
um oh that's blues music all day until
they get drunk enough in the Tupac and
then yeah
did you consider yourself like a hip-hop
head though growing up or not so much oh
yeah bro I used to recite like every
song like I used to know I could still
do that [ __ ] I mean yeah I used to
listen to music a lot like I had every
little iPhone to listen to that [ __ ] I
mean uh every iPod on this [ __ ] start
coming out yeah I used to listen to
music bro but I still choose Ice Cube
over icy yeah yeah Andy starting my
Friday and [ __ ] like I was just childish
for me just the other [ __ ] too
um I mean he did Barber Shop yeah uh
damn I don't know
other kids movies
one of them maybe or something whatever
Are We There Yet yeah so like that but
for me I mean I take Ice Cube but but if
you I don't know yeah I mean just
overall it's cute okay Training Day Pulp
Fiction
yeah do you think they nailed it in
terms of just because like for me
growing up in New York my whole concept
of La was through movies and music I
always knew I wanted to be out here I
grew up in the [ __ ] Tundra eight ten
feet of snow you know what I mean so my
mind was like out in L.A but all I had
was music music and movies and [ __ ] yeah
but yeah so anyway do you feel like
training day like these movies that
depicted the gangs and all the [ __ ] was
that like accurately well done yeah I
mean you you training day Mexican scene
was [ __ ] scary scary somewhere and
and you got people that feel like they
control where you playing right now not
your house necessarily but I mean people
standing outside
[ __ ] like that like the whole movie yeah
that's the jungle too yeah yeah
Raiders or Rams
I don't even really I would have to I
mean I'm gonna have to go with I guess
the Rams right now then because they're
La yeah but we're talking 90s they were
both oh well 90s the Raiders growing up
Raiders okay I forgot Raiders because I
had Raider um tennis shoes
okay yeah as a kid yeah wait
tennis shoes like with the logo on yeah
like from the website and [ __ ] or from w
i mean from Warehouse Shoe Sale WSS yeah
yeah okay damn I forgot about the
[ __ ] little raider emblem on the it
was on the side huh yeah I had the G on
this [ __ ] I mean the G I mean the
Hurricanes games yeah
[Music]
I'm still trying to look for La gears
adult size so I can light up [ __ ] when I
walk those are hard you remember those
yeah oh man I should have got my kids on
man yeah
all right last one you don't really
think of these La movies what they are
White Men Can't Jump or rush hour in the
90s
rush hour yeah rush hour yeah I'm not
even gonna lie to you hold on when's the
last time you guys watched Rush Hour
years ago I watched it about three four
days ago
doesn't hold up as much oh [ __ ] what
yeah because yeah because I thought like
I thought it was crazy you're funny when
I was and then I watched him like
it was up there like it's funny but it's
not like
I was dying as the kid of Jackie Chan's
it hits himself in the thing like I was
cracking up as a kid but yeah I mean
rush hours don't I watched all how many
of them hit the movies though all three
and how many of the white man I mean uh
they're only one of them right Rush Hour
was such a big head though man that's
why they had to do Chris Tucker's just
he's just [ __ ] the man that's why I
don't know he just tweaked out and don't
even want to do movies no more I don't
know what he's doing right now lost the
damn mind I don't know what he's doing I
haven't heard of Chris Tucker in so long
and it's all this money he can come back
and do whatever he wanted right now I
haven't even thought about it damn I'm
just trying to like and things like he a
stand-up or something dude his stand-up
was funny as [ __ ] when he was a kid he
doesn't smoke weed so he don't want to
be on Friday yeah he doesn't smoke weed
anymore so he's like I don't want to
depict somebody that's a weed smoker
it's like you're an actor you also
you're already him yeah you're wearing a
cop in rush hour either [ __ ]
come on man sorry your detective Tucker
I love Chris Tucker I'm not trying to
talk [ __ ] I'm just saying
that was a good movie
that's a good [ __ ] movie man
that concludes who are in the 90s this
is a good one dude I like that that was
a good segment thank you 90s Edition all
right man well dude we've been here hour
and a half let's go that was quick that
was quick super [ __ ] up that was fast
uh before we got it can you tell me
where can everybody find you at social
media wise I know your Instagram gets
[ __ ] like mine yeah I'm just my I'm on
uh YouTube It's milk TV really it's milk
TV yeah I'm good looking Slayer milk on
Instagram Gilligan Slayer yeah
um so just YouTube basically yeah I mean
I got that Instagram is good against
Slayer but they'd be like squeaking on
it do you [ __ ] with Twitter uh nah make
it it's just use it Twitter and YouTube
are a good combination together to grow
just letting you know now people that
[ __ ] with Twitter heavy [ __ ] YouTube
Heavy I've noticed fan wise and people
that I just noticed the crossover it's
never as much Instagram it's YouTube and
Twitter just try it I'm I'm gonna try to
do the uh the Instagram again but I'm
not really going I'ma just post pictures
really yeah just build it like that I'm
not really gonna post nothing crazy
Twitter's uncensored you can post
clips of your [ __ ] uh stuff like say you
want to sell like you have a merge or
something Instagram might take it down
Twitter will never take your [ __ ] down
yeah Instagram be on like I post all my
weed on Twitter all my weeds here all my
crazy explicit like stuff that I'm not
supposed to like I showed like 100
pounds on my [ __ ] Twitter like it's
fine so you should do that you know what
I mean like it's just for me to you as
someone that does YouTube and Twitter
they help each other so much man so just
[ __ ] it if you have one thing that
doesn't get deleted [ __ ] you Instagram
they play I'm on my 27th account they
[ __ ] play me I got a lot of them
going this is so annoying you gotta get
a new phone every time or change your IP
address yeah no I have to I didn't even
know what that was at first me neither I
had to learn when I got deleted
I think I have to use another phone and
do it yeah yeah and then the iCloud
don't let me do it yeah yeah it wouldn't
let me be blocked off of it wow yeah
dude um thank you so much for being here
I appreciate it so it's milk TV on
YouTube hopefully by the time this comes
out you hit that 100 that you sick apply
for that plaque it's gonna be so dope
man yeah for sure
yeah it's so sick dude congratulations
yeah for sure man thank you thank you
Marty anything else this was great man
I've been looking forward to this
episode man thank you so much for coming
thank you for being here thank you guys
all right guys this has been the dope as
usual part
of this I'm [ __ ] puffing yeah I think
it was that last joint that zolp I
smoked all right thank you guys so much
for being here this has been the dope as
usual podcast I'm dopeless it's Marty
O'Neal and from It's milk TV have a dope
ass day cool that that last purple we
got
foreign
[Music]